Russell Crowe everybody this is the
Russell Crowe that we know but the actor
looks borderline unrecognizable in his
new role as former CEO of Fox News Roger
Ailes okay Russell Crowe spotted on
Thursday in New York filming for the new
Showtime limited series and here he is
take a look at him yes that is Russell
Crowe
he's completely transformed into Roger
Ailes
aging himself by decades obviously
putting on some weight here I think
we've got a side-by-side of Russell as
Roger and then there's the real Roger
Ailes again the former CEO of Fox News
so the actor takes on this part for show
times new series and according to The
Hollywood Reporter it comes out in 2019
it's going to be an eight episode series
and it will focus specifically on the
last decade of Ailes life of course
including those now infamous sexual
harassment claims made by former Fox
News personality gretchen carlson and
other women they brought those
allegations against him in Rogers Roger
excuse me
Ailes ended up resigning as the CEO of
Fox in summer 2016 in a wake of the
allegations and he did die in May 2017
so that focuses on the last decade but
this series is not the only upcoming
project that will look at the life and
actions of the former Fox News head you
guys might remember a new movie is
coming out with a star-studded cast also
tackling the story of what went down at
Fox Charlize Theron will play megyn
kelly in that new movie here she is
unset as Megan in September I also
talked to Charlize just weeks around a
weeks ago just around this time and she
talked to me a little bit about why she
decided to take on the role of megyn
kelly who in her own right is in some
ways a controversial television
journalist hears that I think it's an
important story it was written really
well and I think it was the writing that
ultimately in the end of the filmmaker
that really made me realize that it was
in the right hands we need to tell these
stories for sure alright so also in that
limited Showtime series with Russell
Crowe will be Naomi Watts she will take
on the role of Gretchen Carr
send us we're getting the limited series
we're getting the movie a lot tackling
what happened there
[Music]
[Applause]